after weeks of heavy bombardment hakif
is breathing a sigh of relief the
Ukrainian military claims to have driven
Russian troops out of the area around
the country's second largest city the
shelling according to Regional
authorities has stopped that Ukraine's
President says his forces still lack the
means to tip the scales in their favor
Vladimir solenski told a visiting U.S
Senate delegation he needs more powerful
weapons
Republican leader Mitch McConnell leads
a U.S Senate delegation on a stroll
through Kiev to show their support for
Ukraine's war effort it was all smiles
and handshakes as they met with
president zelensky
made it clear that smiles and handshakes
and polite Small Talk won't drive the
Russians out of Ukraine his Armed Forces
need more long-range artillery and
strike aircraft to be able to hit
Russian forces and disrupt their supply
lines
Ukraine's general staff said the
Russians were pulling back from khakif
as they pressed their offensive in the
southeast
yeah
residents of villages around kharkif are
coming to terms with the destruction
left in the wake of Russia's retreat
weeks of artillery bombardment and
occupation have taken a heavy toll
Russia launched fresh ground and air
attacks in the Eastern Donetsk Province
aiming to deplete Ukrainian forces and
destroy their fortified positions the
Russian military seems to have an
inexhaustible supply of machinery and
Men President Vladimir zielinski said
that the outcome of the war would depend
on support from Europe and other allies
meanwhile Russian forces still haven't
managed to defeat the last Ukrainian
fighters in the southern city of marupol
families of the soldiers hold up in the
as of style steelworks are asking China
to help negotiate an evacuation of the
wounded
what goes on there is no longer a war
murders are taking place there
hundreds of wounded with no limbs and no
anesthetics while new bombardments
inflict new wounds on already wounded
Fighters they're exhausted and just
below the line of life we want them to
be rescued
she said that for the fighters trapped
inside the steel Works surrendering is
not an option as she believes the
Russians would execute any captured
members of the azov regiment
now dwe correspondent Matisse building
uh joins me now from Kiev Matthias is
hakif now considered a complete victory
for Ukraine's forces
we are hearing that the Russian forces
are withdrawing from the area they're
conducting an orderly Retreat like they
have done in Kiev when they came under
counter offensive from Ukrainian forces
so uh it's not done yet but what we are
seeing is that a victory is uh it is
most probably going to happen in the few
in the next few hours or days
now Russia's blockade of Ukrainian ports
Matthias on the Black Sea is affecting
Millions both inside and outside the
country what is Kiev planning and what
are they capable of doing about this
Ukraine and also the partners in Europe
are trying to get as much grain out of
the country by train or by Road there
are there are some of the grain is
shipped to Romania and uh there are
plans to ship grain to Baltic the ports
of the Baltic states however that route
would have to go via Belarus and it's
far from Clear whether this could happen
as Belarus is a Russian Ally overall
trains cannot export as much grain as
the ports have the capacities are not
the same so we will still see a shortage
of grain
and in a rarity Matisse we get to finish
with some good news Ukraine has won the
Eurovision Song Contest in the midst of
War how is this particular piece of news
received in the country
it's seen as a huge encouragement and
it's been a very important uh win for
the country more morally the president
has said that he wants to hold the next
Eurovision Song Contest in mariupo which
he says will then be
liberated and reconstructed that's of
course a big plan but overall it's seen
as a sign of encouragement and that's
probably what it was meant as if you see
that the popular vote in all in Europe
was almost unanimously in favor of
Ukraine
DW correspondent Matisse bullying in
Kiev thanks so much
now more on that highly symbolic victory
for Ukraine a victory on stage the
Ukrainian Band by the name of kulash
Orchestra it is who has won the
Eurovision song contest
[Music]
[Applause]
the group was favorite going into the
final round
of Stefania which blends traditional
folk music with hip-hop the band was in
fourth place after the jury voted but
swept to Victory thanks to overwhelming
support from fans right across Europe
now usually Ukrainian TV would broadcast
the competition from a studio in Kiev
but after the war broke out producers
moved the broadcast to a secret location
underground our correspondent Army and
Asif joined the crew on what was to turn
out to be a very special night
the big night broadcast from a bunker
it's the night Ukraine aims for
Eurovision glory and the public
broadcasters suspilner is the channel to
tune into
every Ukrainian gonna watch it because
uh we have not so many good moments
right now and this one
um it could be the most wonderful moment
for last three months
in the first week of the War susp
Illness Kiev TV tower was hit by Russian
missiles they were forced to move their
Studio to an undisclosed location and
after that not only we are but all uh
Ukrainian TV TV Crews had to move under
the ground the mood is excited but tense
everyone here wants the show to go off
without a hitch
not just their own broadcast but also
the performance of kalush Orchestra the
band representing Ukraine
the song has been on repeat across the
country for weeks on car radios in
coffee shops and on street corners now
one more time for the judges
[Applause]
[Music]
kalusha's song Stefania just came on and
people came running down from other
rooms to come watch it on TV here now
these are journalists but it's clear
they have a preference in this show
the votes are in
[Music]
Ukraine wins it's the kind of
announcement you don't often get to make
on Ukrainian TV anymore good news I'm
very excited I'm so proud for my country
it is a big pleasure for us to see it
I can cry I can laugh it it just very
very cool I still can't believe that
it's true uh thank you so much to all
all the viewers all the people from
Europe a very very hot emotion because
uh uh still uh Devina
war in Ukraine and it's uh it's a little
piece of happiness for us
it's not the big victory day everyone
here is waiting for but it's still
something to celebrate
our foreign ministers from naito
countries are here in Berlin for talks
dominated by the Russian invasion of
Ukraine representatives from Sweden and
Finland are also in town to discuss
their intentions to gain membership to
the North Atlantic Treaty Organization
but not all NATO members are Keen to let
the Scandinavian countries become part
of the defense Alliance
U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
arriving in Berlin for NATO talks at the
time the alliance is seeing a sharp rise
in its geopolitical relevance
the talks are focused on long-term goals
but more immediately the accession of
Finland and Sweden are also on the table
not only should Sweden and Finland join
NATO but they should do so quickly of
course I'll have a good conversation
with my counterpart it is important that
we have also consensus consensus could
be an issue native member turkey accuses
Sweden and Finland of harboring militant
Kurds Turkish people predominantly a big
majority of the Turkish people are
against the membership of those
countries who are supporting pkk ypg
terrorist organization and they are
asking us to block this membership
Finland at least is confident this issue
can be smoothed out
Accord to my good colleague
foreign minister and a little bit to
take the tensions down and we will also
meet me today and I'm I'm sure that we
will find a solution to to this item
Unity is key in the alliance as it looks
to the Future in these Berlin talks how
to further reinforce NATO's presence in
Eastern Europe given the tensions with
Russia and for the first time to lay out
guidance on dealing with China
DW correspondent Alexander van Damen is
in Berlin following this meeting for us
Alexandra given those comments from the
Turkish foreign minister how difficult
is that pathway for Finland and Sweden
toward NATO membership
well we had a chance here to speak with
many foreign ministers and I have to say
that most of them were very optimistic
and and confident that turkey will come
around that they will not undermine the
alliances unity and will not eventually
block or keep they will drop their
opposition to Sweden and Finland joining
the alliance and some of them indicated
that turkey might have domestic reasons
or some bilateral issues with some
allies there are rumors that the reason
for turkey's objection could be could be
restrictions on weapons deliveries to
the country the us as we know also
imposed sanctions on Turkey after the
country decided to buy russian-made air
defense systems so all of this is sort
of on the table but we have to say that
most ministers here were very optimistic
that in the end the accession process
for Sweden and Finland should they
declare officially that they want to
join the alliance will be quick and
smooth
Vladimir Putin's nightmare has long been
NATO expansion how serious a Finland and
indeed NATO taking Russian threats of
retaliation to this move
well I think that any threats coming out
of Russia are being taken seriously by
NATO and of course by Finland as well as
we know as you just mentioned Russia has
vowed what they call military and
technically retaliation we know that
they are threatening to move more troops
towards their border with Finland which
is a very long 1300 kilometers that
could be cyber attacks
and they have already announced to
suspend deliveries of electricity to
Finland that is however something that
Finland can deal with they have a new
power a nuclear power plant they have
wind energy so they're not very
concerned about that and the thinking
here is also that you know Russia is
threatening to retaliate however Russia
have suffered huge losses in Ukraine and
actually their army is busy there just
briefly Alexander this landscape is
Shifting daily what else is on the
agenda while this meeting is going on
The Continuous support
NATO allies for Ukraine of course and
then they're also talking about a
long-term strategic concept for NATO
that should address new challenges and
risks of course Russia's aggression but
also China's role on the international
stage
DW correspondent Alexander fundament in
Berlin thanks so much